und jetzt gehen wir direkt an die Front
direkt in den Krieg hinein es gibt
weitere Rückeroberungen seitens der
Ukraine als Momentum wird das sogar
gewertet seitens der USA wie groß ist
dieses Momentum wie kann das jetzt der
Ukraine eine wirkliche Wende vielleicht
in diesem Krieg gab bringen wir gehen
direkt dort an die Front wir gehen zu
unserem Reporter Paul ronsheimer jetzt
live zugeschaltet es gab ein Telefonat
zwischen dem Kanzler und Putin und dort
wurde darauf zu aufgefordert Paul dass
man jetzt doch diesen Moment sehen soll
dass man das doch einsehen soll wir
wollen gleich über das Telefonat reden
aber erst einmal über die Situation
jetzt bei dir was spielt sich dort ab
wie groß ist dieses Momentum dort in den
Gebieten östlich von krakev jetzt gerade
für die Ukraine
der Patricia wir sind in Richtung Front
gefahren also in den befreiten Gebiet
bin fünf Kilometer entfernt von butanzia
also der Stadt wo immer noch gekämpft
wird und du sprichst Wladimir Putin an
und ich zeige euch einmal hier etwas das
ist eine russische
Militäruniform die dort einfach auf dem
Boden liegt hier bei uns in dieser
Richtung wir haben viele viele Panzer
gesehen die in diese Richtung gegangen
ist viele ukrainische Panzer wir sind
unterwegs hier mit ukrainischen Soldaten
ich kann das einmal zeigen ausgestattet
hier mit Darling das ist die einzige
Möglichkeit um zu kommunizieren um
überhaupt eine Kommunikation zu haben
und diese Gruppe mit denen wir dort in
diese Stadt in diese immer noch
umkämpfte stand wollen die sind hier
versammelt man kann sagen die Ukraine
haben ein Momentum und mich interessiert
vor allem auch die eine Frage die
Deutschland so bewegt und einer der
kommandierenden hier ich möchte einmal
Fragen zu
weapon Sohn
[Musik]
Waffen sind wichtig um mir
weiterzukommen um für die Feier zu
kämpfen wir haben gerade einen Einstieg
hier aufgehört in der Nähe
Leopard ist im Tor privat
also
klare Ansagen hier von der ukrainischen
Seite wann braucht Panzer und weiter zu
machen wir haben hier einige gesehen die
in Richtung Boden und die weiterfahren
denn sie wollen weitere Gebiete hier
erobern du sagst es Paul es gibt jetzt
gerade Meldungen Gerüchte noch dass eine
große Offensive auf lohansk geplant ist
kannst du dafür eine Bestätigung finden
in diesem Moment
eine Bestätigung für diese große
Offensive haben wir nicht wir wissen
aber von ukrainischer Seite dass man
weitermachen will dass man weitere
Gebiete erobern will und dass man sich
damit nicht zufrieden gibt Lukas das
wäre eine mittelgroße Sensation Kreis so
klar muss man das sagen denn eigentlich
wollte Wladimir Putin bis gestern diese
Gebiete vollständig erobert haben
Donnerstag wollte ursprünglich dass dort
auch Referenten stattfinden also
illegale Abstimmung darüber über den
Anschluss an Russland all das
funktioniert jetzt nicht mehr und die
große Frage ist wie wird der am Ende
reagiert die Zuschauer noch mal kurz
einen Eindruck zu geben wo du dich im
Moment befindest Paul und wie groß diese
Geländegewinne in den vergangenen Tagen
in den vergangenen Wochen sind der
ukrainischen Armee noch mal schnell der
Blick auf die Karte also sie sehen hier
unterschiedliche eingefärbt erst die
Gebiete eben die Russisch waren und
jetzt sehen Sie unten im Zeitverlauf die
Gebiete die dann in den vergangenen
Tagen in den vergangenen Wochen eben
wieder an die ukrainische Armee an die
ukra zurückgekommen sind zurück erobert
worden sag ein bisschen was über die
Moral dort in der Truppe die müssen sich
im Moment ja oben auf ein wenig fühlen
absolut Kai die Moral in der
ukrainischen Gruppe aber auch was die
Bevölkerung angeht die schwappt fast
überall kann man sagen die Frage ist
hält das also ist sozusagen dieser Wende
wirklich so groß wie sie momentan
aussieht oder könnte und davor waren
auch US Militärs ist wieder eine ja
Offensive dann von russischer Seite
geben weil man hier jetzt eben sehr sehr
viel Gebiet erobert hat ich zeig das
noch mal wie hier einfach die Armee
Uniform der Russen auf der Straße liegt
einfach weggeworfen dass versinnbild
nicht so ein bisschen das versehentlich
dich so ein bisschen wie schnell ihr
alles gehen musste und wir haben an den
Straßenecken überall Panzer gesehen
überall das gesehen was hier passiert
und immer noch passiert in den
vergangenen Tagen kein und neben der
Unternehmen dem ukrainischen Militär
muss man sagen wir waren in diesem
befreiten Gebieten gestern unterwegs
unglaublich emotionale Szenen von alten
Frauen die im Szenen ausbrechen und uns
darüber berichten was ihr erlebt haben
in den vergangenen Wochen und die sagen
dass sie nicht mehr damit gerechnet
hatten dass die Ukrainer ihre Stadt ihr
Dorf befallen wird peinem ist noch
einmal ein bisschen mit in deine
Situation wo du da gerade bist du stehst
neben einer ganz hektisch dort liegen
gelassen in der russischen
Militäruniform du begleitest ukrainische
Soldaten die derzeit ein Momentum haben
so sieht es die Welt so sehen Sie es
selber dir selbst eine Moral haben die
er diesen ganzen Krieg schon hat sich so
anders entwickeln lassen als viele es
gedacht haben nimm uns einmal mit uns
mit rein in diese Situation du
begleitest diese Männer die jetzt ganz
klar ein Ziel vor Augen haben mehr denn
je in diesem Krieg
so ist es Patricia also das ist eine
kleine Truppe von Leuten die jetzt in
diese Stadt wieder
vorwollen und dort ihre Kameraden
treffen wollen zu ganz das ist eine
Stadt in der heftige Kämpfe immer noch
sind wir haben auch gerade ich weiß
nicht ob wir hören Gottes Schlag gehört
und sie sind ausgestattet hier wir
zeigen vielleicht einmal die Ecke
sie sind aus sie sind aus diese die sind
ausgestattet hier an der Front und
versuchen dann weiter zu kommen also
eine kleine Gruppe mit denen wir
unterwegs sind und die jetzt sozusagen
versucht dir
weiterzukommen und dort dann mit
weiteren Militärs in der Stadt zu
sprechen sie wissen auch nicht genau wie
es dort aussieht auf die Stadt erst vor
wenigen Tagen teilweise bezahlt aber auf
der anderen Seite des Flusses immer noch
heftige Kämpfe und man will dann
weiterkommen und man hofft darauf dass
jetzt dieses Momentum auf das
psychologische Momentum hält und dass
man es schafft weitere weitere Region
erobern und das ist ein Wechselbad der
Gefühle auch für dich in diesem so
langen Krieg BILD-Reporter paurons haben
wir noch ein Wort zu den Orten die jetzt
wieder befreit worden sind was siehst du
da also du hast über die Emotionen
gerade gesprochen aber siehst du auch
neue Kriegsverbrechen
wir hören von möglichen Kriegsverbrechen
Kai bislang ist mein Eindruck das ist
das in der Dimension nicht vergleichbar
ist mit dem was für ein guter gesehen
haben muss ja hunderte Zivilisten gab
die umgebracht wurden wir hören aber von
Folter wir hören davon dass
elektrofolter eingesetzt worden sein
soll wir hören davor das Anwohner
Zivilisten eingesperrt wurden das sind
alles Dinge die jetzt untersucht werden
müssen genau untersucht werden müssen
aber ja auch in diesen ordnen denen wir
warten wir waren ist wieder
schreckliches Geschäft Paul ronsheimer
berichtet von der Front in der Ukraine
vielen herzlichen Dank Paul für deine
information
[Musik]